الاخبار اهلا بكم في تطور غير مسبوق اعلن
المتحدث باسم
فقدان مسيرات امريكيه متطوره بعد اصطدام
مقاتله روسيه بها فوق البحر الاسود
واشار رايدر الى ان المسيره كانت تقوم
بمهمه استطلاع فوق المياه الدوليه حين
اعترضتها مقاتلتان روسيتان بطريقه غير
مهنيه حسب قوله وبينما اكتفر بالتاكيد على
انها طائره استطلاع احجب البنتاجون عن
الافصاح عن المهمه التي كانت تقوم بها
في المقابل قالت وزاره الدفاع الروسيه
انها رصدت مسيره امريكيه قرب شبه جزيره
القرم تتجه نحو الحدود الروسيه وهي تغلق
نظام التعريف الخاص بها واضافت ان المسيره
الامريكيه سقطت في المياه دون تعرض لها
وبينما اعلنت الخارجيه الامريكيه عن
استدعاء السفير الروسي لديها اناتولي
انتنوف لتسليمه رساله احتجاج على الحادثه
نقلت شبكه سي ان ان عن انتونوف قوله ان
بلاده لا تريد مواجهه مع الولايات المتحده
وتفضل عدم خلق وضع يمكن ان تحدث فيه
اشتباكات او حوادث غير مقصوده بين البلدين
قالت وزاره الدفاع الروسيه ان قواتها
تتقدم من الجهه الشماليه الغربيه لمدينه
باخموت شرق اوكرانيا واكد رئيس شركه فاغنر
الروسيه العسكريه الخاصه ان القوات
الاوكرانيه تحضر لهجوم مضاد في
جهته قال الرئيس الاوكراني
بعد اجتماعه مع القياده العليا للجيش انه
تم اتخاذ قرار بمواصله الحفاظ على مدينه
وحمايتها
قالت شركه روستخار الروسيه للتصنيع
العسكري ان انتاج الذخيره في البلاد وصل
الى مستوى حاله الحرب من جهته اعلن الرئيس
الروسي فلاديمير بوتين ان الصراع القائم
في اوكرانيا هدفه الدفاع عن وجود الدوله
الروسيه على حد قوله
قالت وزاره الخارجيه الصينيه ان صفقه
الغواصه الامريكيه الاستراليه البريطانيه
تنتهك معاهده عدم انتشار الاسلحه النوويه
وجددت الوزاره رفضها للصفقه واعتبرتها
تهديدا للامن العالمي من جهه قال وزير
الخارجيه
انشاء العالم
الانجلوساكسوني تكتلات اعلى غرار اوكوس
ودفع البنيه التحتيه الى اسيا يعد اعلانا
جدا للمواجهه طويله
نقلت رويترز عن وزير الداخليه الباكستاني
ان الشرطه ستعتقل رئيس الوزراء السابق
عمران خان وتقدمه للعداله وقد تجددت
الاشتباكات في لاهور بين انصار خان
والشرطه الباكستانيه بعد وصول فريق من
الشرطه الاعتقاله من جهته اتهم عمران خان
الشرطه برفض تسلم تعهد رسمي بمثوله امام
القضاء السبت المقبل
ختام الموجز الى اللقاء